Je suis sûr qu'ils ont perdu, mes fans ont
tellement confiance que vous connaissez ma bouche et tout, donc
c'est juste que vous le sachiez parce
qu'il y a quatre ans, je vivais ici
aujourd'hui,
donc comme si j'étais presque au chaud, vous savez pour
aider à en faire un  meilleur endroit,
je suis capable de vivre mon rêve et je suis capable
de faire beaucoup de bonnes choses et fondamentalement,
tu connais ma religion, tu sais, je veux dire, je
ne le fais même pas, je n'envisage même pas une
religion, tu sais, je pense juste  étant
comme si j'étais un chrétien tu sais que je crois
en Dieu je crois que tu sais que Jésus
est mort sur la croix pour mes péchés je crois
que tu sais que tu sais j'aime j'ai
une relation avec je suis capable de
lui parler et  vraiment, c'est la raison pour laquelle
je suis ici, donc je dois absolument que vous
sachiez que
[Musique] [
Musique]
[Musique]
Je n'ai jamais su que tout cela était possible,
j'ai déménagé à Atlanta, juste comme j'espérais
et juste  cela a demandé beaucoup de travail acharné et
beaucoup de dévouement mais vous savez, il
dit toujours que tout est possible mais vous
devez juste apprendre dur mes histoires que vous
connaissez sont bien différentes de la guérison
[Applaudissements]
heureux que vous sachiez que j'ai autant de grands
fans  ici et tout ce soutien a
été incroyable
[Musique]
construit environ 15 écoles et plus à
venir. Je sais juste que je trouve que c'est formidable
que des jeunes comme moi puissent
aider d'autres jeunes
[Musique] [
Musique]
[Musique]
[  Musique]
vous voulez savoir ce qui ne va pas avec ce qui
se passe avec la célébrité en Amérique aujourd'hui,
ce qui ne va pas dans le fait d'être un succès et bien
c'est le meilleur exemple, ce gamin qui n'a
rien fait sauf essayer de devenir un
succès dans la musique a parfois changé sa vie
dans un cauchemar et vous vous demandez
pourquoi il se bat parfois contre
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
Je n'abandonne jamais mais encore une fois je dois mettre sur
de que para muchos un autre campus
prendra un
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
elle est une de mes  meilleurs amis une de mes
meilleures amies tu ne l'appellerais pas une
petite amie elle est une de mes meilleures
amies c'est sûr
très diplomate Justin non je t'ai demandé
des choses pour moi tu sais
[Musique]
Je me vois tu sais avoir 30 ans genre
marié comme probablement je ne sais pas c'est
comme si c'était loin maintenant
mais comme peut-être que je veux être un jeune papa
tu sais que je ne veux pas être vieux et ne pas
pouvoir tu sais taper dans le
ballon de football
[Musique  ]
en tant qu'humains, nous sommes imparfaits mon passé mes
erreurs toutes les choses que j'ai
vécues Je crois que je suis là où
je suis censé être et Dieu m'a là
où il me veut
[Applaudissements]
vous